نذهب الان الى الرياض التي تستعد بعد اقل
من ساعه كذلك لاستقبال العام الجديد 2023
عبد المحسن الحربي معنا من هناك من
البوليفارد في الرياض عبد المحسن كل عام
وانت بخير مره اخرى الاجواء عندك
كل عام وانتم بخير صهيب بالفعل لا تزال
الاجواء هنا وتوافد الناس همم جدا عالي في
هذه اللحظات قبل اقل من ساعه على بدايه
هذا العام الجديد الناس بداوا
يتوافدون منذ ساعات التذاكر ايضا نفذت قبل
همم ساعات من هذا همم من هذا اليوم وهذه
الساعات الاخيره في هذا العام شاهد
الاجواء من حولي الكل مستمتع وقادم ليودع
هذه السنه سواء في المطاعم الكافيهات
والمقاهي الموجوده هنا في بوليفار سيتي
بالاضافه الى جزء اخر ذهب للاستمتاع باخر
ساعات هذه هذا اليوم وهذا هذه السنه في
همم مسرح محمد عبده ارينا همم حضور الحفله
الكبيره التي يحيي 12 فنانه وفنانه عربيه
في هذه اللحظات همم بدات هذه الحفله قبل
من ساعه ونصف تقريبا وتستمر حتى ساعتين من
الان في
وجوكر فالي كبير تعيشه الرياض دعني صهيب
اخذ بعض اللقاءات مع الاشخاص الذين قدموا
في اخر ساعات 20 22 ايش امنياتك جاي هنا
تودع السنه همم 22 في بهذه الاجواء في
بوليفار دراسه طبعا اجواء بسيط انه اول
مره بس ما شاء الله شيء بجنن حلو ومن خدمه
النظافه كل شيء طبعا تمام تمام حلو
نتمنى الخير للجميع طبعا السنه الجديده
كثير طبعا
اول شيء تحاليل فلسطين ان شاء الله للسنه
الجديده
من جميع الناس في اهاليهم
وبالنوصل تحياتي لاهل فلسطين
لجميع العامل وشكرا الى السعوديه الرياض
بالخصوص وانت كمان ايش امنياتك للسنه
الجديده امنيات شخصيه على مستوى الدراسه
على مستوى الامور الشخصيه فلسطين
شكرا
على مستوى بلد على مستوى الشخصي همم
يتمنون سنه سعيده تتحقق فيها كل امنياتهم
في ظل هذا الاجواء الاحتفاليه واجواء
احتفاليه
سابقا الاجواء بارده جدا وانا كنت اختبرت
برد الرياض الحقيقه البرد شديد على ما مع
هذه السنه الجديده اذا في العاصمه
السعوديه حدثني عن برنامج الاحتفالات
بالعام الجديد عندك عبد المحسن
نعم هنالك برامج مختلفه تقام بالتزامن مع
نهايه السنه في الحقيقه كما ذكرت صهيب
درجه الحراره اا تصل الى ثمان درجات وهي
من ابرد ايام السنه في هذه الاوقات في
الرياض لانه كما تشاهد همم عدد من الاشخاص
تواجدوا في هذه المنطقه دخلوا الى الداخل
لتواجدون في المنطقه المحيطه في هذه همم
الشاشات همم الاستمتاع بهذه الاوقات واخر
الدقائق من هذا العام بالاضافه الى تواجد
اصلا فعاليات تقام بشكل يومي هنا في
بوليفارد ريال سيتي قبل اقل من ساعتين كان
هنالك العاب ناريه في هذه المنطقه مجدوله
همم مسبقا نستمتع بها كل الحضور ايضا
بالاضافه الى بوليفارد ورد الذي يقع
بالقرب من هذا المكان عدد من الفعاليات
التي تقام في في هذه اللحظات قبل ساعات
واا الان وبعد همم دقائق ايضا سيكون هنالك
فعاليات وكل مستمتعه حتى الذي يريد ان
يذهب الى بلوف بوليفارد ورد من هذه
المنطقه يستطيع الذهاب عبر ال- اا
التلفريك الذي يربط هذه المنطقهتين
الترفيهيتين الكبيرهتين في هذا الموقع من
الرياض اذا كل مستمتع جدول مليء همم
بالاحتفالات وبايضا الانشطه المختلفه